elon musk takes aim at ula says parent
company
lockheed darkened the skies and lobby so
you know the whole story about that
do you know the whole story behind why
there's a controversy there between
these two guys
yeah the military industries let me read
it to you and you'll see kind of what
the difference is because that's exactly
what you just said here so
elon musk takes aim at ula's his parent
company lockheed dark in the skies and
lobbyists this is a fox business story
spacex founder and ceo elon musk is
continuing his criticism
of the united launch association for
accepting government money musk's
criticism came in on a wednesday tweet
when he responded to a comment from ula
president and ceo ceo
tony bruno who suggested that ula's a
vulcan
centaur rocket could compete with
spacex's reusable rockets ula would be
dead as a door nail without the tool
launch
provided dod requirement musk tweeted
referencing on air force contract
called the eelv launch capability
payment worth hundreds of millions of
dollars per year must continue
if this is not true then you won't have
a problem removing it
your parent company lockheed darkened
the skies with lobbyists to ensure f-35
was single source in 2014 spacex sued
the air force
over its contract given solely to ula
hence
monopoly the two entities reached a
settlement in 2015. you know who helped
uh help this settlement be be done john
mccain
musk's callout is the following he's
saying it costs you
twice as much of taxpayers money to go
to space than it costs me
why are you spending taxpayers money the
way you are so he's calling out
one is a private company which is who
spacex the other one is a public
company which is what ula this is crony
capitalism
corruption this is this is not only this
is a perfect
example of what happens if there is no
competition yeah this is the perfect
example what happens if they don't have
competition
and elon musk is calling it out yeah
which is needed of course it's needed in
every possible way it's needed
i mean look you know it's interesting
you see this crony capitalism i see this
as the the
this is the essential downfall of
socialism and centralization
this is where the government picks its
winners and looters
and there's no competition and there's
no market force involved well there's no
market force to say
like we talked about this a couple weeks
ago where it was like elon musk was the
first person
he's definitely not the first person in
nasa that was like you know what we
should bring the rockets back and reuse
them like we got these flying
buildings maybe you don't drop them in
the ocean these things cost a lot of
money
but it was just taxpayer money they were
like ah who needs it let's build it
there goes that pen
yeah dude like it's gone so he
when you're in the market you know when
you're when you have
shareholders to answer to accountability
accountability accountability
it's a good thing right now i'm not
saying that government doesn't
necessarily
have a place in investing in places
because capitalism has really struggled
in two places specifically
they struggle in uh research development
and they struggle in art
all right so artists all of our artists
end up being you know
hyper socialists and and communists
because
when they're coming up in their
developmental stages there is no
market for them and their stuff does
take a lot of time it takes a lot of
time to become
good at being an actor a bodybuilder
right how much
time does it take to get your body how
much effort does it take to get your
place
your your physical being in a place
where you're like yeah i could be
professionally good looking like that
takes a long time right
but there's no money along that stretch
right there's nothing there's no
incentive you've got a 10-year plan
where there's no way you're going to
generate revenue out of what
you're spending all your time effort and
energy on so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you